all right hi everybody it's Nick
Gillespie this is the region live stream
we have these every Thursday at 1pm
Eastern time I hope that you'll uh come
to the next one as well as stay for all
of this one which is great I'm extremely
happy to be talking about today's topic
which is whether Boomers and gen xers
more or less can get along with
Millennials and gen Z The Prompt for my
conversation or for this conversation
has to do with a uh a recent poll that
was taken uh that uh Liz Nolan Brown who
we'll be talking to in a second wrote up
for reason this was done by Newsweek but
uh the finding was kind of stunning I
got a lot of play 44 of Millennials want
to make misgendering a crime we're going
to get back to that in a second I want
to introduce my guests uh today who are
and let me just get rid of this my guest
today are Liz Nolan Brown she's a senior
editor at reason a millennial who has
written a lot about generational kind of
identity and kind of uh conflict over
the past couple of years as uh as have I
and Gene twangy who is a psychologist at
San Diego State University and the
author of many books most recently the
uh book that is just out called
generations and uh here we have a slide
of her uh of her uvra Generations as the
real differences between gen Z
Millennials gen ax Boomers and silence
and what they mean for America's future
she's also written igen generation me
and the narcissism epidemic uh Gene
twangy thanks for talking to reason
thanks for having me on all right so
let's um you know the first before
before we get into the meat of the issue
about this you know a parent turn
against free speech or wide-ranging
speech among Millennials and gen z uh
that seems very much at odds with the
kind of tradition or the ethos or the
mythology maybe of uh of baby boomer and
uh and Gen X
um I want to go through some of the
stuff that is in Gene's book because
it's it's extremely helpful to
um talk about
uh you know where we're going through uh
Gene your book is called generations and
it takes you know the idea that
Generations matter that birth cohorts
share broad characteristics that are
meaningful
um these are the uh Generations that you
go through uh in your book there's the
silent generation which is 1925 to 1945
there are about six percent of the
current population and dropping uh there
is where did uh baby boomers go there
from 46 to 64 about 21 of the population
I myself am a light Boomer and one of
the things that's great in Gene's book
everybody who appears has a birth year
next to them so you can start to realize
why you dislike them the way as as
deeply as you do a Gen X which Gene is a
member of is uh about 18.5 percent of
the population they're the Jan Brady of
generations right the middle child the
neglected the benignly neglected middle
child I think Millennials of course 1980
to 1994 they are about 21 20.5 percent
of the population and then gen Z which
is coming up faster gen Z is 11 to 28
years old now they're 23 percent of the
population
um Gene I guess before we go to the next
slide about this what what prompted you
to write this book at this moment
so my previous book igen is about gen Z
and at the core of it it's really about
how
technology like smartphones and social
media
fundamentally changed the lives of teens
and young adults
a lot of mental health issues that
happen at that time they also start
spending less time with each other in
person just had some really big impacts
so you know I gave a lot of talks around
the country college campuses high
schools corporations and when I would
talk about the impact of the smartphone
one of the most frequent questions that
I got was well wait hasn't that affected
everyone and of course the answer to
that is yes it may have affected people
differently depending on their age but
it got me starting to think about
that broader picture
of how technology has
is really behind so much cultural change
and how that cultural change has
created generational differences and
when I say technology I don't just mean
you know the recent stuff like
smartphones and social media it's
everything it's labor-saving devices
better Medical Care faster
Transportation air conditioning the
birth control pill all these things that
have these Downstream effects on how we
live yeah and you're kind of uh and I I
I've put myself more or less in this
Camp as well you're kind of a
technological determinist right that
technology it's not everything but
technology is really the main driver for
why Society is the way it is and changes
over time is that accurate it is yeah I
mean you know the traditional theory of
cultural change and particularly
Generations
is okay major events happen economic
recessions
pandemics Wars and that's how the
generations are how they are
problem with that theory is that major
events tend to be short-term in their
impact and with a few exceptions of
course don't tend to impact you know how
the speed of development or values or
you know a lot of the things that really
really get to the core so you see the
model here and the basic idea is that
technology is at the root of so many of
these other changes technology has a
direct effect on generational
differences so gen Z spending much more
time online and less time with their
friends when their teens is one example
of that but it also has these mediating
factors so it is behind the rise in
individualism more focus on the self and
less on others it's behind development
slowing down because we have better
Medical Care through technology people
live longer
and the whole development developmental
trajectory slows down from infancy to
old age so kids are less independent
teens are less likely to get their
driver's license or have a job young
adults take longer to marry to settle
into careers to have children and
middle-aged people look and feel younger
than their parents or grandparents did
at the same age
uh that is for sure here's here's a uh
diagram or uh sorry let me go back to
that uh yeah there's a kind of diagram
of what's going on or the technology
model of generations you talk about
um what in um for the baby boom and this
is something that uh I I was remarking
on
um I read an interview with Lorraine
Newman who was one of the original
members of Saturday Night Live which
premiered in 1975 and she was talking
about how the baby boom and she's an
early Boomer so probably born in the
very uh in the mid 40s or late 40s uh
but she was talking about how they're
the first generation raised on TV uh my
parents who were born in the 20s uh you
know I they told me when they got their
first TV that they watched it like they
called in sick to work and just watched
it for as long it was on because it was
this new amazing machine but they were
in their I don't know you know like 20s
or 30s it affected them differently than
if you're a kid growing up so if we can
look
um at you know if if television is kind
of the big technology and again it's not
the only one by any stretch uh for Baby
Boomers what what is the big technology
for Gen X and for millennials
so for Boomers I would also probably
throw in the impact of labor-saving
devices in the home right yeah because
that had a huge impact on particularly
on women right and Boomers were the
first ones to really live a lot of those
differences so Gen X you know we're in
the middle
for Gen X a lot of the same influences
were there it's just it twists a little
differently so for Gen X it wasn't just
that the TV was around it was also it
was there for birth as opposed to
Boomers where I was a little bit later
uh you just take it for granted that it
was there
um it's just a lot more programming for
kids
um just and video games
also started to become really big for
Gen X so that that's another
technological influence
um for Millennials I would say the
internet
um and instant messaging
and the beginnings of social media which
were a little different from the way
social media is now but uh things like
Friendster and Myspace
and then for Gen Z it's the smartphone
and let's call it modern social media
things like Instagram and Tick Tock yeah
uh Liz does uh you know does that
comport with you the the sense as a
millennial and you you remember a time
before smartphones certainly but also uh
the internet to some degree but you know
was you know kind of instant messaging
and uh you know that kind of
interconnected technology that was
always on I can remember getting my
first broadband connection I think was
in 1998 and that was a game changer as
an adult but I would think as a you know
as a teenager as an adolescent suddenly
things you know that that just became
dominant
older end of the millennial Spectrum so
um
I got I got on AOL and instant messenger
when I was thinking
I don't know Junior High maybe
um so yeah that I mean that was
definitely a big that was my first
internet experience was logging on
through through AOL with the thing where
you still had dial up and you still had
you know an AOL account and chat rooms
and that was like your whole internet
experience but um you know I think
especially the older Millennials like we
went through every rapid change in in
Internet adoption like
um I was never on Friendster I was on
Myspace um that was you know I was on
live Journal live Journal was big when I
was in college
um and then you know I was I was the
oldest person on Facebook for a while
because you had to you know have a
college account to create a Facebook a
college email address to create a
Facebook account and I was I was a
senior when it opened up outside of a
few schools so like you know I was yeah
from on Facebook from the beginning on
Twitter from the beginning so I think
that's the interesting thing is yeah
we've been on we've been a lot of us
have been on every different iteration
of social media platforms since the very
beginning which is why now also with you
know uh Twitter imploding and other
things like that like there's all these
new ones like threads and blue sky and I
I leaped to join them all because I'm so
used to that but I'm like I got a bit of
a social media fatigue at this point
like I don't know how yeah I hear you
how many of you platforms I can join
no I uh you know I feel like uh the
Harry Potter horcrux uh scenario where
you're you're parking more and more
little bits of yourself all over the
place so that it yeah you don't get
wiped out and you just get dissipated by
that I think in a in a literal and
figurative like in a profound way uh
Gene what about the political or they're
not simply political events let me get
back to that um chart that you have or
the diagram
for uh this yeah what are what are the
events you know certainly with uh I I
love you the emphasis in the book about
how labor-saving devices really
radically altered household life and set
the set the ability for women to start
going back to work not so much in the
50s but in the 60s and especially the
70s suddenly you know you didn't need
somebody to take care of the household
um and the 1950s are bizarre decade um
in American uh kind of uh psychic life
because conservatives in the 80s started
talking about them as the great last
great decade where women stayed home at
work and people didn't get divorced but
they were a complete aberration they
were also filled with a huge amount of
anxiety about juvenile delinquency about
drugs about homosexuality about uh you
know illiteracy about losing to the
Russians in the Space Race but we have
this odd notion of the 50s as a Placid
period which really isn't but but when
we talk about the the Boomers what were
the major events that really kind of
triggered their world and uh you know
then what what is that with the
millennials so for Boomers you know it
really starts with World War II at their
Origins so that was their parents and
that's why the baby boom began as the
soldiers coming back from war so that's
one reason that baby boom begins with us
born in 1946.
but what was odd and there still really
isn't a great explanation for is why the
baby boom continued after about 1950 or
so right because and its peak year was
57.57 which is crazy when you think
about it maybe people figured out they
enjoyed sex I don't know or children
yeah or both well as a parent yeah I I
know which one I prefer more but yeah
but yeah total fertility yeah 1957
um was it at nearly four children
so yeah just bigger families were in
Vogue you know you had the huge baby
boom and that's much higher than it was
in the 1930s it's not linear I mean
that's what's so interesting and so that
had a huge impact on the baby boom
because they were such an enormous
generation so they shaped the culture at
at every age because they were so big so
that's the first one but then um then we
get to all of the things that happened
when Boomers were teens and young adults
that had such a big imp impact and they
had a big impact on like the Vietnam War
right
um the Civil Rights Movement although
that the leaders of the Civil Rights
Movement the feminist movement and LGBT
Rights Movement were silence and
greatest actually but the Boomers were
some of the folks you know kind of
behind the scenes and the younger people
on those in those movements and
organizations
and they lived those changes so the
silent generation so people like Martin
Luther King Ruth Bader Ginsburg they
were the ones that kind of got things
changed and then it was the Boomers who
lived a lot of those I always think
about that in terms of Timothy Leary who
is technically I guess by this schema is
uh actually the greatest generation is
born in the early 20s but you know his
impact was mostly on Boomers so that you
know in this these fuzzy categories
things are over there you know there's
no reason to be pedantic or you know
didactic when something begins or ends
but so you have all of that what about
for Millennials what are you know what
are the events that Define uh their kind
of psychic uh landscape
most Millennials mention 9 11. that's
often the first thing that that comes to
mind for them
um
but uh maybe Liz can talk about that a
little bit more too yeah
um I mean that that would have been the
first thing I mentioned I don't I don't
know if it's because not necessarily
because it you know
uh had the biggest impact on on me or
other Millennial psyches but at least
it's the the big one that we think of I
think
when you talk about our generation
um the the reset like the Great
Recession the housing crisis of the late
auth some yeah was was another picture
can I ask about 9 11 though is it um and
especially Liz I know I mean you were
growing up in Southwestern Ohio and
Cincinnati so it was it's not like you
grew up in lower Manhattan or or in New
York or you know near the Pentagon or
something like that was the the amount
of space that it took up in your head
was it because it was being discussed
all the time
um and obviously it also radically
altered government policy on a wide
variety of uh in a wide variety of ways
and things like that but this to me is
one of the things that's always
interesting is that many of the events
that end up shaping how we think or and
how we feel about things are less you
know it's not like the Great Depression
where it's like okay the economy is
completely scattered it's a kind of
symbolic event which ultimately you know
with 911 Heaven the damage was you know
awful disgusting disturbing but it was
fairly limited and we recovered from it
fairly quickly
yeah I mean
I mean 9 11 in my mind is all tied up
you know in in Afghanistan or in the
Iraq War and everything and like I knew
a lot of people who who fought in those
Wars um you know like from a very
working class area so I had a lot of
friends over there and uh so I mean so
there was that I mean that that's I
think the big one about how it affected
Millennials is like that was
you know our Millennials were were
fighting over there in Afghanistan and
Iraq and that had a big impact um you
know on everyone in our Our Generation
um and and yeah just also how it changed
politics but first sorry I need to
apologize because I have like a severe
cold right now too so I'm a little bit
cloudy edited and I think I sound very
but um
you know but I always think about how my
freshman year of college there was this
show on called that's my bush and it was
like about George W bush and it was I
forget I don't know who made it it was
made by the south archives yeah Matt
Brown and Trey Parker
just like
yeah it just portrayed him as just like
a complete bumbling idiot right like and
it was just like that was the trajectory
that the George W bush presidency was
going in he was just going to be a joke
and you know the butt of you know this
and then and then all of a sudden he
became this like great hero figure to a
lot of people and who was you know
uniting our nation in these troubling
times and it was just it felt like
everything we knew about the political
like you know our that we've had this
fledgling ideas about the political
system and and what was going on right
that in politics just was totally
interrupted and so I think that was that
was very sort of unsettling to see um I
mean I don't I don't think that all
Millennials were were obviously you know
skeptical of of the whole rhetoric
around 9 11 but I know you know a lot
were and a lot of people my age everyone
I knew was at the time so it was you
know opposition to opposition to the
Iraq and Afghanistan there's opposition
to this sort of very nationalistic um
often you know racist or urgingoistic
rhetoric that sort of came in the wake
of 9 11 was a very uniting factor for
for a lot of people in our generation I
think uh Gene you uh would have as a uh
Jen uh excerpt you would have been
coming up and this is you know as
somebody who's in the second half of the
baby boom by the time I was in high
school I was being taught by by people
who went to Woodstock about what pieces
of [__] my cohort was you know we were
indifferent and we didn't do anything
you know it was kind of I remember
joking at some point you know it's like
oh they had the Manson family we had the
Menendez brothers we were just living in
a you know in a fallen lesser age and it
was like screw you which is a very Gen X
point of view and also where you know uh
the uh Vietnam War and all the lies
about that Watergate all of the
um high profile
um you know that while the economic uh
lassitude of the 70s as well as you know
people like Gerald Ford and Jimmy Carter
Jimmy Carter falling during a Fun Run
and battling with a uh a killer rabbit
in a canoe and things like that
um you know for you as a gen xer what
was the what was the kind of psychic
world you were growing up in
well I think I didn't even really become
aware of some of this until the early I
think the early 90s was really the big
turning point for Gen X in terms of
Gen X being recognized as a separate
generation right um we were named after
a Douglas Copeland novel that came out
tonight Copeland born in 60 or 61. right
so he's really yeah by most people's
definition so that the that kind of
recognition
um that there was maybe something else
going on actually did begin with people
born in the early 60s not the late 60s
where the the most people put the the
dividing line because I think that that
experience was different you know if
you're born in 63 you know how old were
you in Woodstock happened no elementary
school early Elementary School yeah yeah
right so I think I think at that point
there started to be that kind of
recognition of there was some kind of a
break that there was the Boomers
who had those kind of quintessential you
know late 60s early 70s type of
experiences and then everybody else and
yeah nobody knew really knew what to do
with us and it was the idea of um you
know those late bloomers and gen xers of
you know we're all depressed and we're
black all the time and then we're junky
and we're gonna you know ruin the
country and like all this kind of stuff
and Slackers right exactly
right like and then by 94 we had like
movies like uh Reality Bites
um singles you know all of those kind of
it was like it it it's very interesting
to look back on this especially given
our current cultural moment of
negativity and pessimism
early 90s were a time of that as well it
was there was a lot of pessimism a lot
of cynicism a lot of the books that um
came out around that time talking about
Gen X
um were like Gen X is not going to do as
well as the Baby Boomers economically
here's all these statistics about how
terrible they're doing
but then we all know what happened next
what happened next was
the tech boom the economy just took off
and
although you know Gene exercise that
reputation for you know they were they
were the Slackers and you know
unemployed
it turn on a dime by you know the mid
1990s it was oh no they're they're the
internet millionaires or the tech
millionaires yeah yeah people like Marca
Andresen coming up with what became
Netscape the inner interconnected or the
networked uh computer system that became
first you know the internet and the
world yeah Yahoo Google YouTube all of
those were founded by gen xers and it's
fascinating also to think you know that
the end of the Soviet Union or the end
of the Cold War more properly
um freed up people from having to be
ultra serious right like we were no
longer in a Twilight Struggle now you
could kind of go to Burning Man and you
didn't have to feel apologetic about it
or anything like that I also think you
know this is always and you know I'm I'm
laying all of this out because I think
we're going to come to this more when we
talk about kind of millennial speech
attitude towards speech versus Boomers
um you know Bill Clinton was the first
Boomer president and he seemed
impossibly young he was 43 I think when
he was elected but he was not a gen xer
he was he was the guy who went to boys
state he was the guy who you know was
somehow shook John F Kennedy's hands you
know same with Al Gore they were not
what gen xers were they were like ass
kissers you know student pres student
council president types and whether it's
good or bad it's just they seem to be
quite different
um so then we get to
um you know let's can I add one more
thing please I think I think this is
relevant to um to sort of what we're
going to discuss later too if if I think
of like the other big political thing
that informed I think or at least you
know the millennial politics like aside
from the whole war on terror stuff was
was like the gay marriage battles
because that was you know just when we
were in high school and college and that
went you know in our early 20s that was
sort of dominating politics um all the
different fights in the state and all of
that and uh and really driving a lot of
a lot of why why the political tribalism
so I think yeah that was very important
one thing that's one thing that's uh you
know amazing and Gene's book goes into
this quite a bit that you know the
younger you are the more likely you are
to be completely comfortable with all
kinds of sexual orientation and you know
particularly something like gay marriage
um uh Liz what was it that you know kind
of sensitized you or your cohort to that
as an important thing and and I guess a
leading question here how much of it was
it was something that you you and your
friends took for granted that your
parents were kind of like hemming and
Hong about
that it was a way of separating you from
your parents or one's parents
I don't know I think a lot of our
parents we're a little bit opposed but
came around about the issue during
during that time like I know that my
parents um sort of were like kind of a
knee-jerk like well no they shouldn't
and then like when they thought about it
for three seconds they were like
actually I don't know why I'm a post and
they they changed their mind over the
course of you know a very short time um
as as the issue was was in the spotlight
and and so I think that actually that
was you know it wasn't it wasn't I don't
think a generational issue per se
um I I think it did you know it it did
matter a lot that a lot of us had just
come up with with knowing gay people in
a way that were out in a way that like
other Generations didn't so it just
seemed like of course you know this is
this is the thing that should be allowed
but um you know on the other on the
other hand it was also sort of just
foisted upon us
look and we're really using that well
both parties were really using that as a
wedge issue and I get out the vote I
mean and it's worth pointing out sort of
you couldn't ignore it yeah that people
like Bill Clinton certainly but Hillary
Clinton even Barack Obama when he was
elected president was openly against gay
marriage against marriage equality
um so the the speed with which these old
you know kind of uh certainties die it's
real you know it's amazing
um Gene can you talk a little bit about
the impact of the financial crisis you
know the housing bubble exploded in or
popped in 2006 or thereabouts the
financial crisis kicked in in 2008 and
you know it's funny
um there was a massive recession in the
early 80s
um my brother who's older than me was
born in 1959 graduated into that and
people were like you know this is the
worst downturn since the depression a
decade later Bill Clinton got elected
partly by arguing that what in hindsight
is a relatively minor recession was the
worst depress recession since the Great
Depression and like people were like
didn't we just hear this but then in the
late odds we had something that was
actually the worst economic downturn
since the Great Depression how did that
change things or how did that scatter
categories and informed generational
identity
yeah so that is
often the second and sometimes even the
first major event to come to mind when
we're talking about Millennials because
it had such a big impact on their
day-to-day lives I mean had that impact
across all generations and we have to
recognize that but for millennials
a lot of them depending on when they
were born but were yeah they were
graduating high school graduating from
college entering an extremely
challenging job market
and that
was a big hit you know for their
Financial Health
um
it didn't last forever though we'll get
into that they did recover from that but
that was obviously a huge shaping
influence it also led to things like
Occupy Wall Street
[Music]
millennial-led movement a lot more
awareness around income inequality
um it was I I mean trust in government
had been declining yeah well it's been a
straight line decline really since yeah
there's some interesting ups and downs
to it but the Great Recession was like
kind of the final blow
um because so that was that was the
other piece of it yeah and how did um
what about Obama and Liz I'd be curious
I mean I don't think we actually knew
each other in and around 2008 but Obama
seemed to be you know a messiah right
that you know after all of the [__]
you know after uh you know Bill Clinton
where economically things went well but
you know he hollowed out a lot of trust
and confidence in the presidency the
election of 2000 which was obscure and
vague and its outcome uh then Bush then
911 then a lot of lies about why the war
was being prosecuted uh how it was being
paid for and things like that and then
you have a figure like Obama who is
youthful also a baby boomer but uh is
black and you know he is promising hope
and change and kind of not explicitly
but implicitly offering a kind of escape
from uh racial you know of a very
tortured racial history
um Liz how did how did Obama appearing
on the scene affect you and and your
friends
I mean yeah he definitely came at the
exact right time for everyone to be like
hey like this guy I mean especially
coming out of the Bush years right where
it just seemed like you know social
conservatism and a very sort of old
stuffy sort of social conservatism was
still sort of a you know and then and
Obama just being like such a radical
departure from that even though in a
radical departure from like some of the
you know the war on terror rhetoric even
though he wasn't you know necessarily no
and even like still opposing gay
marriage and things like that I don't
you know when you look at what is his
actual some of his actual policies were
I don't know why everyone exactly had
that impression it was much more I think
about the the rhetoric and the aura
around Obama than necessarily anything
you know he eventually did or anything
but but that was you know we were at the
right age I think to really need to
change and to want to believe that it
was possible and I think that a lot of
us even people who were you know I was
considered myself a Libertarian at the
time but I was
um one of the two times I voted in
presidential elections uh what was uh
bonus for Obama and um
I think also then Obama kind the Obama
years kind of contributed to a
disillusionment later amongst
Millennials too because you had this
like oh Things Are Gonna Change you know
things gonna be a lot different and um
and then you know a lot of people
he was you know the first politician
that was like oh I believed it and then
he was disappointed therefore you know
I've learned yeah that you might have
cared about and
yeah the you know the obviously the
economy did it did not bounce back
quickly it took a very long time uh but
I always think uh you know and I I I'm
cautious about imposing my feelings on
on other people but the revelations by
Edward Snowden that info you know we
some people thought with credit you know
with some reasons that Obama was an
anti-war candidate but he wasn't and
then the Snowden Revelations and Snowden
being a very great Millennial right uh
along with people like Jolene Assange I
suppose is also uh he might be Gen X but
you know we we found it was kind of Meet
the I mean Millennials might not
understand the reference to the whose
song uh but you know it's like meet the
new boss same as the old boss that we
weren't yeah I think that was we were
just changing you know putting wine in
new bottles or something like that uh
Gene how does that um you know I guess
this is a broad question that may not
have a good answer or may not be a good
question actually but how does politics
figure in all of this as opposed to kind
of material conditions so
um you know the fact is is that the
economy after it hits trough shortly
after Obama became president it started
picking up slowly but we had a massive
recovery period which which followed
into Trump but it doesn't seem that
material conditions necessarily are what
are really dictating the kind of vibe of
the country or the vibe of particular
Generations
absolutely so I mean this this is one of
the questions
that I spent a lot of time on in the
book I spent a lot of time thinking
about because it's a real mystery
the economy started to do a lot better
after especially after about 2011.
um it was a turning point and just it
just roared back you know the stock
market came back unemployment went very
very low if you look at unemployment say
right before covid it's extremely low
things are going very very well median
incomes were going up
um
yet that didn't really reflect the mood
in the country right now some of that as
you mentioned politics is because of
trump and that had some you know
I think most people would agree a fairly
negative impact on the national
conversation and the and uh how
different but it's it's also kind of the
fact that he was possible you know
reflected massive what you know well hey
like what yeah you know absolutely and
so I you know I think and I think you
have to you have to look at that closely
and um
there were a few things that I found in
doing the analyzes for the book that I
think it go a long way toward explaining
the rise of of trump and populism in
general
um so one example is it used to be that
and you looked at say depression and
happiness and if you looked at it by
social class education income
um occupational Prestige things like
this
for the silent generation for example
there really wasn't a whole lot of
difference
for happiness and mental health
depending on social class and then that
started to change so I had a lot of
grass in the book
um
and those lines diverge they diverge
starting with the Boomers and then go
from there where
in more recent years you end up with a
very big gap for happiness and
depression
by education level and income
so
people with a college education for
example
happiness has stayed fairly stable
levels of depression fairly stable among
older people anyway
and then
lower income
those who don't have a college education
big increases so this these diverging
lines it really suggests that for this
segment of the country
um working class let's call them
huge amounts of dissatisfaction
and that explains Trump in a lot of ways
uh can I just uh uh Linger on this a
little bit you also point out something
that's really fascinating that you know
and and well as as to backfill a little
bit and you know I'm genuinely obsessed
with these kind of generational issues
because my parents were born in 1923 and
1927 so technically in your schema one
is greatest generation one is uh silent
generation but they are so in my mind so
clearly part of the same generation
um in the experiences that have the
attitudes that they formed and and you
know so many different things go into
that but one of the things that is
fascinating to me is that you show that
it's really the baby boom generation
when depression
kicks in or when when this kind of
existential I I prefer to think of it as
existential lengths that's when it
kicked in my parents were not happy
people they were not wealthy people they
were not educated people
um but they kind of expected life to
suck they would talk often about how you
know so they were born to Immigrant
families uh in the 20s then the
depressed you know and they were dealing
with a bunch of [__] then then the
Depression hit then World War II my
father served in World War II at the end
of the war after you know even after uh
Vijay day he my mother said well we just
we were glad the war was over but we
just expected Our Lives to be a flat
line of kind of pretty shitty a little
bit better than subsistence level
existence but not much because their
entire life had been kind of flat
economically and then something changed
you know do you think that do you think
that this is actually a change in like
you know the prevalence of of this sort
of existential angst the prevalence of
depression things like that or just a
change in our our cultural language
around it we know for sure
yeah and sorry to jump in but no no
um yeah we we know for sure that that
isn't it because you also see the same
Trends in things like suicide
and self-harm and so on uh and the the
trends for of those objectively measured
behaviors are almost exactly the same as
the trends and say reports of symptoms
um and that's what that's when we're
talking about these things it's not
based on diagnoses it's not based on
people be be more willing to talk about
things publicly it's Anonymous surveys
about symptoms which once most people
don't even know are depression and these
objectively measured behaviors but the
but the rise and the I mean the Boomers
among all the other firsts that they
either were or they claim to is they're
the first massively unhappy cohort right
yes and then Gen X also not great a
little bit better the next was kind of
flat you know I mean so early on in
their teen years the suicide rate was
way up for for Gen X but there may be
other reasons for that
um because that's that the that's one of
the few places where the suicide
statistics kind of diverged from some of
the depression ones but yeah I mean it's
the if you look across all the
generations it's kind of a complex
picture for the trends in mental health
um
the silent generation actually a better
mental health than the greatest
Generation before them maybe because
they they didn't fight in World War II
didn't and didn't have the huge impact
of the Great Depression uh and then for
Boomers it gets significantly worse yeah
much more depression than and on
unhappiness and suicide rates go up uh
Gen X kind of stays the course right I
mean a couple of couple surveys even
looks a little better at least as adults
um when they were younger not so much a
lot of unhappiness
um and then Millennials very mixed
picture for Millennials for mental
health
um as young people a lot of things
improved actually happiness actually
went up among teens
um depression went down by a little bit
but as adults not so much depression
starts to increase again and then for
Gen Z that is a place where we have
extremely consistent data across pretty
much every survey and indicator that
mental health got a lot worse for teens
and young adults starting around 2012.
yeah so yeah I'm I'm skeptical though
like what if what if their Generations I
mean they were dealing with at the same
level of mental health issues they just
dealt with it in different ways because
you know there is there's some evidence
that things like you know attention to
suicides can increase people's you know
propensity to think that is the solution
whereas you know maybe you're depressed
you're depressed like 30 something or 40
something in the 1930s and you just like
quietly drink yourself to death instead
of necessarily you know taking your own
life like I I don't know I I don't think
it's necessarily different suicide rates
I think if that were true you would see
a linear Trend and it's not a linear
Trend it goes in and out so the silent
generation actually a better mental
health than the greatest before them
from the data but it is I wouldn't
expect that curve if it was just oh the
older Generations are more stoic or
something but it was a curve there is
something odd going on where as America
kind of like kicks free of material uh
poverty or Misery after World War II
where everybody you know and there's
there's disparities in wealth but like
the Baseline most people have housing
you know clothing shell alter some level
or access to education and
dissatisfaction with life goes up I mean
to me it seems that it's you know we
have succeeded you know far beyond
Abraham Maslow's greatest dreams of
bumping up the hierarchy of needs and
it's like oh yeah the one thing that you
need to do then is also invent meaning
and significance on a daily basis I mean
we're all existentialism we're living in
a world where all of those institutions
that kind of channeled our energy or
restricted our choices have started to
fade because Gene one of one of the I
think great themes in your book is about
and this you know goes back to at least
the beginning of the Industrial
Revolution or the modern period
modernity
um that people are more individualistic
uh people have more choices and you know
I hate to you know quote Spider-Man but
you know with great uh with great power
comes great responsibility right like
we're all left having to make sense of
Our Lives at a time when all the
institutions that either did that for us
or told us shut up don't do don't think
just follow tradition they're all kind
of missing right yeah I mean this this
began with the Boomers and this is the
Dilemma that's still with us today that
a lot of these traditional rules
were really really restrictive
um a lot of them would now
be labeled you know racist and sexist
and homophobic oh God they I mean they
were right they were absolutely right
yeah yeah right yeah for sure
um
and they were they were so they
restricted opportunity for great numbers
of people
um so you know I would rather live in
this world than that one for sure uh but
with that said you know when you have
structure
there's not as many choices you're not
searching for meaning as much technology
comes into play too
because
of
this basic piece that
used to be life is about survival right
I think about my grandmother a lot so my
grandmother
uh and grandfather ran a dairy farm in
rural Minnesota they had eight children
they didn't have time to think about
self-esteem or what the meaning of life
was they were just surviving
right
um well let's let's shift to uh start
talking about some you know one of the
great things about the Boomers uh I'm
always reminded whenever I think about
this uh when Saving Private Ryan
was uh coming out David Spielberg did an
interview with Roger Ebert where he said
the most Boomer thing ever which was you
know the point of World War II was was
the baby boom going to be born or not
World War II allowed the baby boom to be
born and it's like that is the most
insane reading
right you know but it's also perfect you
know it captures something unique about
the baby boom and the baby boom of
course spent a lot of time hating on
their parents uh you know who had not
only given you know food clothing and
shelter to them but unparalleled
opportunities and education and you know
extra pairs of pants and TV shows in a
world you know food made especially just
for kids
um and now we're kind of going through
something similar um and I've written
about this a lot I know Liz has has
touched on this Gene obviously your work
does but a reason
um you know there's generational Warfare
going on in all sorts of different ways
or this is cover story from uh reason in
2012 and it's more about old age
entitlements and the argument that I'm
making there with the co-author is that
old age entitlements are really taking
money from you know relatively poor
relatively young people are giving it to
relatively old and relatively wealthy
people
um we have
um a little bit later uh we wrote this
uh wonderful story
uh again with a co-author about
Millennials this is from 2015 and it was
um about how Millennials are charting
their own course and that that's a good
thing let me read a short quote uh from
near the conclusion of this when it
comes to politics generation independent
which is what we were calling them is
already turning tuning out their Boomer
and Gen X Elders like so much Bob Seger
on their parents car radios that is as
it should be the future always belongs
to the young who must find their own way
in the world yet it would be a shame if
this new generation gap gets in the way
of the sort of transgenerational
solidarity that could make the future so
much easier for all of us to navigate uh
they rummage Millennials rummage through
past Generations experiences and
attitudes like gen xers used to rummage
through Salvation Army stores mostly
though Millennials aren't listening to
you because you're not speaking a
language that makes sense to them they
are young they want to set their world
on fire and they can and well burn
brighter than the sun without asking
anyone's permission that reads like it's
from a different planet these days
because Millennials uh and Liz please
speak from your own experience seem to
be a particularly sour bunch of people
right now who insist that they are being
screwed you know beyond any more than
any generation ever Gene recently wrote
and this is an excerpt in the Atlantic
that came out earlier this year from her
book Generations the myth of the broke
Millennial after a rough start the
generation is thriving why doesn't it
feel that way I guess uh first before
then I want to talk about the the poll
that I mentioned at the beginning of
this and attitudes towards free speech
and kind of openness
um Liz do you agree that Millennials
today seem kind of sour compared to
maybe a decade ago
um or is that overdoing it but if they
are you know what changed what what
what's stoking the anger
um I don't know that like in the in the
quote unquote real world that
Millennials are necessarily more you
know sour angry depressed about their
prospects now than they than they were
you know in in 2013 or so um you know if
I mean obviously like you Gene mentioned
uh Opera
um Occupy Wall Street earlier I mean
there was there was a lot of there was a
lot of discontent and a lot of anger
there at the time too
um but I also think that today the idea
that we're all you know very discontent
and disgruntled and bitter about
everything is is not my experience when
I'm like you know just like talking to
friends in in my everyday life and
things like that um but I think you know
um there is a there is a grievance
culture that started getting rewarded
online in in you know when like when the
VC money was flooding into starting like
a billion Publications like Mike and
they needed to fail content and it was
all like ah let's like talk about how
racist and sexist everything is like you
know this this like yogurt commercial is
like the worst because you know yeah
whatever it was all just like you know
intense critiques about how everything
was was terrible even though we were
objectively getting you know much much
better in these sort of aggressive
attitudes and you know that sort of
thing started because there was just so
much you know money going into pumping
out a stream of endless media and blog
posts and things like that and then it
got Amplified because of um you know the
incentives on social media and the
incentives for people to become
um you know to go viral and things like
that and and I just think that that sort
of um
that's sort of very aggrieved discontent
disposition and and posturing has really
been rewarded online over the past you
know decade or so and that's contributed
to I mean and then in turn probably has
influenced the way that Millennials
think about themselves to a degree but I
also think it's just um partly that
that's what is the most visible for us
when we think about people in this
cohort because that's what we're seeing
from like the most prominent
commentators and things like that
Gene could you talk a little bit about
why
um it seems Millennials
um you know and not just them but uh the
media in general perhaps
um but why haven't they updated their
statistics uh you know because if you if
you look at 2010 it's I guess not good
for Millennials if you look at it now
things are actually good my most
traditional indicators of wealth per
capita income home ownership rates
um things like that
um what what is holding people back from
kind of starting to deal with what's
going on now as opposed to what was
happening or what might have been
happening in the past yeah you know I I
think there are some
some there is a little bit of reality in
some of these attitudes so for one thing
the gains in median income
are almost all among women so that's a
good news story but it also means then
you have a heterosexual couple they want
to have children to keep up both of
those incomes you need to pay for child
care so in that in that way some of the
economic complaints do do hold some
water
um but with that said there is such an
enormous disconnect between how well
Millennials are actually doing
economically and the perception of how
they're doing and the discussion around
how they're doing that it's that's so
vast
I I think it's clear that there has to
be some perception rather than just
reality there
um and the stuff Liz mentioned I think
is right on I think that that has a fair
amount to do with it just that
negativity is rewarded online it's
rewarded on social media anger gets
clicks negative news gets clicks
positive news not so much
um so if you're gonna go online and and
talk about how Millennials are doing so
badly
that's going to get retweeted that's
going to get more clicks on your news
story than some of the good news pieces
um but I think there there still is a
little bit of a mystery here
um
with the economic perceptions
that's not just about millennials
and it's not even just about the economy
it's like why is everyone so pessimistic
right now like there was a a poll
research a poll sorry a Pew Research
Center poll
um a few months ago and it's across all
ages and it was you know are things
going well you know there's a country on
the right track it was those types of
things and it was it was more
pessimistic
than
in 2021
you know when we were not coming out of
the pandemic
um it it's incredible that like right
now
people are more negative
than they were when we didn't have a
vaccine
um when we were still in the middle of
of the pandemic
and and there's this very pervasive
argument particularly from gen Z as well
as some Millennials that this is the
worst time this is the worst time ever
everything bad keeps happening nothing
good is ever going to happen again and I
think if you take a step back and say
well wait a second is this really a
worse time in the beginning of the
pandemic is it really a worse time than
the Great Recession is it a worse time
when you know than Vietnam than World
War II than the Great Depression I think
objectively speaking probably not
but there's something going on that's
making people feel very pessimistic
right now
um let's look at uh enough teasing and
this is my uh bashadi organization here
in my uh inability to run I guess I am a
boomer after all to run a slideshow but
let's talk about this poll uh Liz that
you wrote up I think last week for
reason uh 44 of Millennials want to make
misgendering a crime and let me just
read a bit uh uh you write younger
Millennials were most likely to support
criminal penalties for misgendering with
44 of 24 to 30 25 to 34 year old
respondents in favor and just 31 percent
saying misgendering should not be a
crime uh and then you look a little bit
older and you know the 25 to 34 year
olds that includes some gen Z so it's uh
you know Millennial and gen Z but then
some 38 of 35 to 44 year old respondents
said it should be a crime while 35
percent disagreed some 33 percent of 18
to 24 year old respondents which would
be gen Z said it should be a crime while
48 disagreed so you have you know Liz to
you the best of your hypothesizing you
know what is going on that 44 of 25 to
34 year old respondents think that
misgendering somebody should be a crime
um yeah I mean
it's it's they're not thinking about it
they're not thinking it through that's
my that's my most I guess hopeful
interpretation
um is you know people are people are
very concerned with trans rights these
days they're very
um a lot of people you know are very
rightfully think that you should you
know respect people's pronouns respect
people's gender that they consider
themselves and they want to signal that
so when you're asking a survey like
should it be a crime sure why not you
know my hopeful I I think that's nuts
but I may be a prison I may be a prison
abolitionist but I think this should be
a crime yeah so but my like hopeful
interpretation is that people answer
survey questions a lot of times based on
a sort of desirability bias of trying to
say what they think is right and this is
a way to signal that you think it is
wrong to misgender people
but there's no actual proposal attached
to this right there's no like you know
like here's what the criminal penalties
would be here's how much you know time
people would spend in prison or what
they'd have to pay here's how it would
be enforced there's no discussion about
all the all the you know unintended
consequences
um and things like that so I I hope that
you know if if this was an actual
proposal people were actually discussing
it the support would be a lot lower than
um you know than in a poll where it's
just like hey is this you know where
it's more answered almost as if like hey
is this bad people say yeah because
unfortunately we do have you know a we
are in an era where people think that
like anything bad should be a crime sort
of at least before they think it through
what about uh Gene what do you think is
there you know and this poll you know
was done by Newsweek
um the data is not available online I
look around for we don't even know the
exact questioning you know the wording
of the question so all of that those are
serious caveats but it seems to comport
with a general attitude among you know a
large chunk of younger people say people
under 30 or under 35 towards
um not putting up with speech they find
uh
ugly or or uncomfortable what you know
what's your read of something like this
well really jumped out at me
is that the Gen the the purely gen Z the
18 to 24 year olds who are actually less
likely to say that they thought it
should be a crime so yeah I would love
to see that dating because that that's
an interesting result
um it might suggest that maybe a corner
has been turned um and gen Z is like
yeah of course I don't want to misgender
people but no it shouldn't be a crime
maybe they have witnessed enough cancel
culture that they're over it
um but you know because a few years ago
the data we had we have suggest you know
it's much more linear that that the
younger you get the more likely people
would would say no we would need to
restrict speech
um but um and uh yeah let's um I wanna I
wanna run two short clips that kind of
get to this the first is uh something
that I think you know a lot of people
have seen uh this was taken at Yale
University and 2015 and it's Nicholas
christakis who's a faculty member there
and who was the master of a house along
with his wife
um and this was the aftermath of an
email that uh Erica christakis had sent
out suggesting to students that they can
they can come they can police themselves
when it comes to what is or is not a uh
an offensive Halloween costume this is
all a kind of strange thing but I I
wanna I wanna play two clips so this is
from 2015 at Yale uh where Nicholas
christakis you know a very highly
esteemed Professor a baby boomer uh has
gone out to talk to students and let's
watch this
foreign
all right so uh Gene let me ask you just
when you you know and I'm sure you I'm
sure that this first made the rounds
among faculty members at universities
like when you see a confrontation like
that you know with a professor on the
receiving end of a you know screaming
tirade you know how did that make you
feel
well I mean I remember that time there
was certainly a lot of discussion on
campuses uh among faculty members
um I mean they really are the only word
to describe It Was Fear there was you
know it was this realization
that what we thought the rules were
we're no longer true that we thought the
rules were that the university is a
place to have open discussion
and yes we want to be respectful of each
other and yes we want to be respectful
of people of different backgrounds
but
we should be able to discuss things and
that was around the time that a lot of
people started to become afraid that
they would say one thing in class and
get and get fired
[Music]
yeah so uh has that uh changed a bit on
campus for you do you think has that
receded a little bit yeah no I think
it's it's pretty much still there okay
and can I ask is that how does that
affect the way you know not your
research per se because that takes place
outside of the classroom uh you know
although it's all connected but how has
that changed the way you teach
um it hasn't really changed the way that
I teach although I did start to think
twice about I mean I teach psychology
and
so there's never anything controversial
or touchy yeah I got right I mean right
you know and
so I think I just had to go on look I'm
going to present the research do it
respectfully but I always tried to do
that so it didn't really completely
change the the way that that that that I
did things but it did
I did definitely
and I know I can speak for a lot of
other people have had this experience
too it did have a chilling effect it had
the effect of
um being scared to talk about certain
things
of
um of just worrying about it of worrying
about if this goes wrong you know what
could happen will my department back me
up if we have a discussion that goes
sideways even because these types of
things that happen so I think a lot a
lot of Faculty members you know have
watched those news stories coming out
over and over and over and we pay a lot
of attention to them because we try to
figure out what went wrong and you know
what sometimes you can take an object
lesson out of the things that you read
about other times you you just go man
there before the grace of God go I that
that didn't happen in my class I do uh
uh very uh close friend of mine is an
English Professor a full Professor who
is one of probably maybe half a dozen
people who occasionally teaches Amari
Baraka a uh black uh poet and playwright
and author and in his work it was Leroy
Jones and the for part of the 60s became
a Baraka his his work is filled with the
n-word
um and it's it is absolutely provocative
and one you know semester she was
teaching a class in that and a student
not even a student of color objected and
the response was okay well I'm not going
to teach Amory Baraka anymore and so you
get this weird experience where it's
like you know somebody who was on the
the margins of the of the Contemporary
Canon is now just not going to be taught
which I don't think anybody would say oh
that's it's an understandable outcome
it's not a good one Liz what what were
your undergraduate years from when to
when
uh do I have to say yes well you know
you're a millennial and you're an older
Millennial and you're a mother
2000 to 2004. yeah would you have ever
in your life thought of screaming at a
professor like that even if they had
like hit you with a baseball bat
no but
strands were starting even back then
like I got into a lot of fights in this
one English class with um this this
woman who um was upset about some things
I said about about her like Tran her
querying of my Antonia
uh and so she told the professor that I
that I made her feel unsafe in class and
we had to both come to his office and
like discuss how I was making her feel
unsafe that was the language used so I
think that this it was definitely not as
prevalent but I think that this sort of
um
you know language around like Words
making people feel unsafe and ideas
making people feel unsafe was was
starting to percolate even back then
yeah uh for sure
um Gene when were you in grad school
uh in the 1990s yeah and so yeah that's
when I started teaching and I'll tell
you nobody ever said that the idea like
oh we can't discuss this because it is
unsafe that was nobody ever talked about
that that is a very that is a New
Concept yeah that and it's kind of
fascinating my grad school I I was in
undergrad so Liz You Are Forever Young
in comparison to me I was in undergrad
from 81 to 85 I went to grad school in
the late 80s through the early 90s uh in
an English Department that was a hotbed
of post-structural theory and the idea
of making people unsafe was kind of the
whole point uh in lecture you know and
that's why you would invoke various
kinds of post uh modern or
post-structural thinkers was to make
everybody unsafe and to their credit the
professors kind of gave as good as they
got they were you know um uh Gene do you
know when the rhetoric of safety or of
you know that where in an invocation of
me feeling unsafe became a thing and is
that related to one of your earlier
books about narcissism I'm curious
um I I it doesn't really follow the same
trajectory as the changes in narcissism
I think it is more likely to be rooted
in this well it's probably a combination
of the slow life strategy and
individualism but with the slow life
strategy
the slower development parents tend to
have the to make the choice to have
fewer children and nurture them more
carefully so then you start emphasizing
safety a lot more then kids take longer
to grow up
um and so you know one of the analyzes I
did for the book was to look in uh the
Google Books database great resource and
you can look at the change in phrases
like stay safe right um and didn't
really change a lot till starts to go up
you know 1990 so these are things that
really started with Millennials in terms
of just a lot more protection a lot more
emphasis on safety and then they kept
going even more with with Gen Z that
um it was kind of mission creep because
at first it was let's protect kids from
physical dangers then it became let's
protect kids from ever failing and then
it became let's protect kids from ideas
or teenagers or young adults of
that safety is not just physical safety
it's emotional safety it's I don't want
to be uncomfortable uh I don't want to
be in the situation where someone else
agrees with me
um and then it then it wanders into the
the most controversial part of you know
language and you know that that's
offensive and and and
um you know the places where I I think a
lot of people can agree to disagree
where
you know maybe we shouldn't have a KKK
guy come to campus that's kind of true
but then where do you draw that line and
who's to say that any of us is the one
who knows where that line should be
drawn yeah although is it also fair to
say you know and I'm thinking back to
college in the 80s there you know you
would always have
um uh you know every year I I went to
Rutgers as an undergrad and every year
they had a different CIA former CIA
director come to talk to campus and
every year they would be protested
because they were horrible human beings
some of them worse than others but uh
but then they also had trolls right like
you would you would bring in speakers
you knew were going to piss people off
right it seems like that's a more common
thing I mean there's I think you know
college campuses should be totally wide
open uh for all kinds of speakers but
when you invite somebody like Milo
yiannopoulos he is not an intellectual
he has nothing meaningful to say right
which became clear once you know once he
was allowed to actually speak
um you know he didn't really have
anything interesting to say but it's not
simply you know that kids are snowflakes
right it's also true that different
parts of Campus are like let's bring in
the most insane ridiculous out there
speaker that's that might be part of it
right yeah yeah and I really hate the
whole the whole snowflakes
label on on so many levels you know
partially as a psychologist it's like I
think that's often used for people who
actually have depression or real mental
health issues and like yeah let's not
make fun of that okay
um you know plus it is nuanced it is
something where we where you know we're
going to have a you know a wide spectrum
of of opinions about this because yeah
someone like Milo is just a product here
you know he's just trying to make people
mad he doesn't actually have anything to
say
um and you know so when people say that
person or you know as I mentioned like
you know
somebody who is going to advocate
for the KKK or something like that okay
that that's that's maybe in a different
category yeah um but then the idea of
you know someone who is further to the
right or further to the left shouldn't
come to this campus and we shouldn't
have a discussion where it is you know a
more serious intellectual discussion of
ideas I think that's where most people
especially gen xers and Boomers start to
say well wait a second what are we doing
here are we really going to say that we
can't have these folks come to campus
and if they do if you don't like it
don't go to the talk or go to the talk
and ask challenging questions we don't
have to you know disinvite them we don't
have to have a safe space where if you
know this offends you you can go there's
other solutions to this I think that's
what a lot of gen xers and Boomers would
argue anyway Liz you uh you know you
teach now right at University of
Cincinnati and their uh journalism or
Communications program from time to time
I'm a professional affiliate there so we
do guest lectures for okay well well I
mean but you've been on campus yes uh
you know recently and things like that
and I realize uh your undergrad was Ohio
University right uh yes alma mater of uh
Paul Newman and uh Mike Schmidt the
great baseball player as well as uh any
number of other great uh great Americans
uh including uh for two years my ex-wife
uh I love ou but can you make any
judgments like between the people she
went to college with and the students
you're teaching now are encountering do
you see great differences or do you
think those are also uh mostly kind of
hyperbolized in online media
refreshing because you know
you know he's also a journalist and we
were we were both very worried about
going to speaking to to these students
about um you know we did a lot like a
series for one of the political
journalism classes about how to cover
um you know the Trump presidency and and
sort of and just talking about our own
work so I was talking a lot about you
know um like sex work and sex
trafficking and you know uh myths around
that I was talking to I just written a
story for a reason about um sort of um
the anti-asian hate crime you know uh
phenomenon that was happening and now
actually a lot of that had been sort of
overblown so a lot of sort of sensitive
topics that we were like We Are Gonna
Get You know like yelled at by these
students or at least they're gonna put
up a big fight about you know how we're
not you know being what whatever but um
there was none I mean people were like
really respectful people asked questions
people did push back on some ideas
sometimes a little bit but you know in a
way that was very just like measured and
reasonable and just like you'd want a
discussion within that classroom to be
so our actual experience was that like
oh like none and you know this is this
could be for any number of reasons um it
could be that this attitude is just more
prevalence in you know on on certain
sorts of like ivy league or liberal arts
schools as opposed to just you know a
University of Cincinnati very
um you know state school but um
but it was it was refreshing they were
not at all like these sort of uh mods
safety monsters that we that we see in
the nickeras
maybe maybe we hope that uh journalists
I mean I and I'm kind of laughing at
myself or even suggesting this but that
journalists are like okay yeah we're
into controversy in a way that other
major
you know gender studies Majors or
anything like that so yeah
um I want to uh run this is a clip uh
from uh one of the or originating
moments of uh the Free Speech movement
at Berkeley uh which started in 1964 and
it's fascinating because that Free
Speech movement uh on the Berkeley
campus at the time the only people who
could leaflet who could table and give
out materials you had to be either
officially part of the college
Republicans or the college Democrats and
there have been a bunch of people who
have been doing things for
um civil rights uh uh sign ups including
going down to the South to register
voters and whatnot and uh one of the
leaders of that who is just a phenomenal
uh kind of improviser uh improv
improvisational order Mario Savio you
know who showed the you know the kind of
sprezzatora uh that you know was talked
about in Renaissance Italy but he gives
a speech here and I I just I want to run
this because again it's from 64 and I'm
curious to get your sense from both of
you how do you how do you think about
this in comparison to what we you know
uh what we saw in the Yale clip uh from
2015.
when the operation of the machine
becomes so odious makes you so sick at
heart that you can't take part you can't
even passively take part and you've got
to put your bodies upon the gears and
upon the wheels upon the levers by all
the apparatus and you've got to make it
stop and you've got to indicate to the
people who run into the people who own
it that unless you're free the machine
will be prevented from working at all
woof that's pretty good stuff
um Gene what do you know when you listen
to that you know here's an undergraduate
uh assignment compare and contrast with
the Yale video
yeah
um
I mean it's
you have anger in both cases obviously
yeah
um
but they're in 64. it seems
more abstract
more about the system
then in 2015 where it's more personal
yeah
yeah that's kind of fascinating right to
think about
um I mean for me the most striking
similarity is certainly the anger you
know to the idea that anger on campus is
something new seems off uh Liz what
about you have you seen that clip before
um or you know and what's your response
to it
um I I don't think you could necessarily
compare I mean there's definitely you
know you can see a lot of that sort of
anger at the system alive and well
amongst Millennials and gen Z depending
on you know where you are and what the
protest is about like I mean we saw a
ton of that during during a lot of the
you know racial Justice protests in in
2020 and and again before that back in
you know 2014 2015 so I think I think
that's sort of anger at the system is
still very much alive and and well today
I um one of the things I find
fascinating is that in the 60s and I
have spent much of my professional
career trying to be the quizling of the
baby boom generation like I I want to
collaborate with Gen X and with
Millennials and gen Z to sink the
Boomers to get rid of them I think you
know the Boomers tend to be full of
themselves or we are full of ourselves
and all of that kind of stuff but it's
interesting to me that in the 60s
generation of what came after there was
a move to build alternative systems and
alternative communities or to challenge
the system very forthrightly so you you
know people move to communes people
created alternative uh corporations
alternative schools uh the Black
Panthers are one example of this in the
civil rights movement and also the LGBT
uh you know the the gay and lesbian
movement the Gay Liberation movement
women's lib was like [__] you we are
going to do our own thing and we're
gonna exit and that's how we reform
things and what strikes me as a
meaningful change now is that many of
the people and you know on campuses and
Millennials they are actually
petitioning the system
rather than leaving it or even altering
it it's and it's almost as if they
believe on some deep-seated level that
the system is there and it is responsive
to them and it has been because when we
look at the system if the system is
America it is much better in terms of
race in terms of class in terms of
gender and sexual orientation and I
wonder if we've kind of reached a limit
maybe of where you know the the
Grievances that are being put in front
of the system now the system can't
really do much about that I don't Gene
do you have any response to that
I think that might be true
um there is a poll done in 2020
that asks people adults of all ages in
the U.S about things like is America
fundamentally a fair Society or an
unfair society and most Millennials and
gen Z said unfair are there significant
changes needed to the system of American
government
and the vast majority of Millennials and
gen Z said yes so I think that points in
the direction
of maybe a similar some some similar
turning points to things like in in the
late 60s where there's this idea of you
know these small changes in petitioning
is not working
um I think that this is going to be very
interesting to watch in the way forward
if that pessimism and that attitude that
things are broken leads to constructive
change
that could be a very positive result
my fear is that it started to cross over
into let's just burn everything down and
start over
uh Liz what about you how do you um you
know do you do you feel like we are
stuck in a doom Loop uh or you know
we're kind of culturally Doom scrolling
right or something like that or
um is what what would be your preferred
Way Forward
I mean
I think I think you're right in your
diagnosis there and it reminds me of
that you showed that Millennial cover
earlier from 2014. it was my first my
first feature article at reason was in
that and it was uh called rise of a
hipster capitalist which is just such a
cringe title now but
um
yeah yeah well no but the point I made
it some of the points I made it it's
still stand which is that you know we
were not I think Millennials were much
less likely and still are than Gen X to
be concerned with you know selling out
and like you know how the the man and
the corporations were people are like
there's no concept of selling out
amongst money a Millennials want to sell
out
um but you know another another part of
what I talked about was how like there
was much less emphasis on like you just
need to drop out of of you know a
capitalist system and much more on how
like we're gonna change it we were going
to do social good through our companies
and even though you know there's there's
a lot of negativity about there's a
negative rhetoric about capitalism I
think that a lot of Millennials still
believe that that it's possible for
people to do um you know to do good
through business as as opposed to
needing to just totally remove
themselves for the world which is the
same you know same thing kind of another
side of the coin you mentioned about you
know trying to reform reform various
systems of of government and Etc through
the system
um
as far as whether or not that works I
have much more faith on the uh the
capitalism side than I do with the
reforming the the government yeah the
official channels I think a lot of times
it's kind of naive to assume like
these people are creating the problem
and we'll we'll you know use them also
though to to be our to be our cops and
our mediators Etc
I uh yeah I mean like you know if if
America is a irredeemably racist you
know sexist society like you're not
going to get Justice from you know the
people who run the system right by
definition but I think in that um 2015
Millennial cover uh you know the cover
story was a package earpiece other
things in there I think my main
analytical error was that I I really saw
it in positive terms that you know I
think about these things in my family
history my grandparents escaped Old
Europe and worked really shitty jobs and
put up with a lot of stuff so that their
kids yeah I mean we're able to get
drafted in World War II essentially
um but you know my parents had a much
better life than their parents I had a
much better life than my parents uh Gene
in in terms of your slow uh life
strategy you know everything was
stretched out my kids have a very good
life or a lot of options and I at the
end of that Millennial story talked
about how Millennials might be the first
generation that actually gets to do work
that's expresses their core political
ideological cultural commitments and I
think I realize you know like if you're
asking somebody who's 21 to yeah okay
now go now go get a job that expresses
exactly who you are and you know what
not that's a that's too much to ask of
anyone but especially a 21 year old who
may not even know you know ultimately I
didn't know what I really thought when I
was in my early 20s so
um you know it's it's setting people up
for some kind of psychological uh drama
that is is asking too much
um I guess as a final thought uh Gene
let's let's leave let's end with you as
the author of generations the real
differences between gen Z Millennials
Gen X Boomers and silence and what they
mean for America's future what is the
you know what's the what what is your
preferred prescription for bringing
generations and it's not like we need a
Kumbaya moment or something we don't
have to be singing folk songs around a
non-carbon emitting fireplace somewhere
or something but you know what what's
what's a Way Forward where the
generations can actually learn from each
other gain from each other comfort each
other and and kind of help us all get
better
I think it's a couple things so in this
book my number one goal was really
to help us understand each other better
because there's so many stereotypes out
there so many misunderstandings
um I think there's also plenty of people
who just don't even
think about this person who's younger
than me or older than me that they grew
up in a completely different world
um and I think that's what we're
thinking about I think it's worth
understanding and that's why I delved
into all of the the data and
um stories and everything else was
to try to help us you know understand
other Generations better understand our
own generation and ourselves better
but as like the big picture
I think we have to
really grapple with these technological
changes
that
we have to recognize just how
amazing
this world is and how amazing our lives
are compared to people who lived 200
years ago or 100 years ago or 50 years
ago how many
things we enjoy how many conveniences
that we just to put it in terms of time
we live longer lives
and those lives have a lot less drudgery
because of technology and a lot more
convenience because of Technology
so what are we going to do with that
amazing gift of time
are we going to fight with each other on
social media
or are we going to sit down spend time
with each other
discuss issues and actually have a real
conversation I think that's a pretty
easy choice but we've made the opposite
one for a lot of the last few years so I
think that's something to consider
all right well we're going to leave it
there Gene twangy
uh author most recently of generations
thanks so much for joining us and uh Liz
Nolan Brown always great to talk with
you thank